while the battlefield one open beta
doesn't officially start until tomorrow
some battlefield insider members can
start playing today if you signed up for
the free program before august
twenty-first and selected a console of
your choice a code should be arriving in
your inbox sometime today if it hasn't
already a message accompanying the code
also reveals a special incentive if you
reach rank 15 and plan at least four
different days you will unlock a
battlefield 1 beta dog tag this will be
delivered to your account when the game
launches on october 21st if you forgot
to register like me if you're not
starting tomorrow the beta will be
available to all players across
playstation 4 pc and xbox one the
battlefield 1 beta takes players to the
sinai desert map which features
horseback combat a deadly armored train
planes and more there are two modes in
the beta conquest and rush and some
matches can support up to 64 players EA
didn't say when the battlefield 1 beta
will end however we know that it will be
at least four days long in other news
about the beta EA recently confirmed
that it will not require PlayStation
Plus on ps4 though Xbox one owners will
need to have an xbox live gold
membership will you be giving the beta
try let me know in the comments below
and for more on battlefield one keep
your site's locked on the game spot
you